Jedes Jahr heiß erwartet unsere Sendung, in der wir mal einen Einblick in den Rasenfunk-Werkstattraum geben. Ihr habt uns Fragen gestellt, wir haben Antworten. Wer ist wir? Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter und Frank Helmschrott ist auch hier, der Ed Helmi auf Twitter und jetzt geht's los.
Der Rasenfunk.
Da lach ich mir doch einen Arsch ab.
Echt. Alles bla bla bla ist das doch. Alles bla bla bla ist das.
Das Tribünengespräch.
Das ist ja kurios, dass ich unsere Twitter-Namen genannt hab, dabei sind wir eigentlich viel eher auf Blue Sky und Mastodon aktiv. Aber naja, hallo Frank, schön, dass du da bist.
Oder auch gar nicht mehr so wirklich, ja.
Ja, wir machen mal wieder unseren traditionellen Einblick in den Rasenfunk, der im Rahmen des Rasenfunk Royales rauskommt, aber als Tribünengespräch. Ich bin so froh, dass wir das inhaltlich glattgezogen haben. Vielleicht verwirrend ist es aber trotzdem.
Die Gesamtzahl ist immer noch gleichbleibend zum Vorjahr, grob, leicht gestiegen. Tatsächlich war mit der Umstrukturierung der Sendung auch damit verbunden, dass wir die Honorare anpassen mussten. Wir hatten immer so einen Dreier Schritt aus verschiedenen Höhen, die wir gezahlt haben. Wenn du in der letzten Saison in einer Analysesendung zu Gast warst, dann hast du noch mehr bekommen als in einer aktuellen Sendung. Auch weil wir gesagt haben, wir haben versucht, das so auch quasi fair zu machen, weil jetzt ja nicht mehr erwartet wird, dass du alle neun Spiele vorbereitest. Auch deshalb diese Trennung zwischen vier und fünf Spielen. Es gibt natürlich immer noch genügend Gäste, die freiwillig dann alle Spiele gucken. Aber auch daher kam das. So konnten wir das finanzieren, weil wir ja letztlich einen Gast pro Woche mehr haben, durch den Fokus, der ausgelagert ist. Und deswegen, da mussten wir quasi Honorare reduzieren. War aber, also nach dem Feedback, was ich bekommen habe, kein… Ich wurde eher ausgelacht, als ich das erklärt habe, von einigen, muss ich ehrlicherweise sagen. Deswegen, Honorare sind auf ähnlichem Niveau geblieben. Und insgesamt haben wir mehr Honorare gezahlt, weil wir mehr Sendungen produziert haben. Das wird jetzt dann in dem Jahr dann nochmal gesteigert werden, weil wir nochmal mehr Sendungen produzieren. Und dann hoffe ich, dass wir dann irgendwann drüber reden können, ob wir dann an den Honoraren nochmal etwas nach oben gehen. Aber das muss man halt wirtschaftlich vernünftig machen, weil es sind eben wirklich sehr viele. Also ich weiß gerade gar nicht, ich glaube im Jahr 2023 habe ich 280 Honorar-Abrechnungen, also so ungefähr, geschrieben. Und wenn wir jetzt einfach mal sagen, jede davon 5 Euro mehr, dann könnt ihr euch ja selber ausrechnen, das ist schon was. Also das können wir sich einfach so machen.
Damit haben wir diesen Komplex abgeschlossen und gehen jetzt über zur Resonanz, also zu dem, was am Ende in Sachen Reichweite und so herauskommt. Und da ging die erste Frage darum, ob mehr Output denn auch mehr Reichweite bedeutet. Also ist der erhöhte Output denn in der Reichweite zu spüren?
Ich würde sagen, das ist sehr plattformabhängig. Also bei YouTube, du hast es ja vorhin schon angedeutet, haben wir ein ganz tolles Wachstum hingelegt, sind von 6000 AbonnentInnen im April letzten Jahres jetzt bei 10.500. Und da wachsen wir. Ich bilde mir auch ein, dass immer mal wieder neue Leute den Rasenfunk hören, die ich vorher noch nirgendwo den Rasenfunk habe hören sehen, gerade die Einzelsendungen, also die Fokus-Sendungen, die sind halt auch jetzt einfacher, in irgendwelchen Foren zu posten und dann noch anzuhören. Vorher war es halt so, ja hier, spul mal zu zwei Stunden acht Minuten, da geht es dann rund um den VfL Bochum. Jetzt schickst du einfach einen Link und sagst, hörst du es mal an. Also ich würde behaupten, ja, wir haben mehr Reichweite durch das Mehr an Output, was aber logischerweise ja erstmal auch ein mathematischer Effekt ist, weil es eine gewisse Anzahl an Downloads gibt. Deswegen muss man da jetzt vorsichtig sein, sich jetzt nicht auf irgendwelche Zahlen was einzubilden. Die Zahlen sind, glaube ich, alle gut. Und das hängt aber halt auch mit dem hohen Output zusammen. Deswegen ja, mehr Reichweite durch mehr Output. Aber was es wirklich heißt, da müssen wir noch ein bisschen abwarten, oder?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Dirion schließt sich da ein bisschen an an die Frage, ob es denn noch Wachstum gibt oder ob da so eine Gläser, eine Decke erreicht ist. Ich glaube, wir haben das in der Vergangenheit schon mal gesagt, dass sich zum Beispiel die Bundesliga-Analyse schwer tut mit Wachstum. Auch das war ein Grund, warum wir YouTube verstärkt haben, weil wir gesehen haben, da gibt es Wachstum. Das war ja eben auch, was Max schon sagte, dass er das Gefühl hat, dass er bei YouTube immer mal noch neue vorbeikommen. Das ist mit Sicherheit auch das größte Potenziale im Moment. Und am Ende ist ja auch, da kommen wir auch gleich im nächsten Abschnitt nochmal dazu, dieses Thema Social Video, also TikTok, Short Videos bei YouTube, Instagram Reels. Der Grund, warum wir da aktiv geworden sind, ist ja auch ein bisschen, um da auszuloten, was eventuell an Wachstumspotenzial für uns drinsteckt.
Genau. Und die Frage, die da natürlich auch immer kommt, ist, müsst ihr wachsen? In kleinen Rahmen auf jeden Fall, weil es gibt halt einfach eine Anzahl an Menschen, die hört auf, den Rasenfunk zu hören, aus den unterschiedlichsten Gründen. Und dafür brauchen wir einen konstanten Strom an Leuten, die nachkommen. Und für ganz viele Aspekte, die wir vorhin im Teil Inhaltliches und Strukturen und Organisationen hatten, da ist halt neben Zeit Geld oft der limitierende Faktor. Also wir wollen ja nicht deshalb wachsen, weil wir zwei in Lamborghini brauchen. Das wird auch schwer mit dem Rasenfunk, obwohl ihr uns so toll supportet, sondern weil wir eben dieses Format Rasenfunk weiterentwickeln wollen. Und da muss man schon sagen, der Gesamtmarkt zu Audio-Inhalten, die sich mit Fußball beschäftigen, der hat sich einfach krass gewandelt und das hat in diesem Jahr nochmal zugenommen. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das zur EM wird. Denn bisher war es so, dass Turniere für uns immer sehr wichtig waren. Die waren ähnlich wichtig wie der Royale. Da haben wir oft hohe Reichweiten gehabt und da haben wir oft neue Leute für den Rasenfunk interessiert. Allein dadurch, dass wir eben ganz lange Zeit das einzige oder eins von wenigen Formaten waren, das eben zu jedem Spiel eine Sendung gemacht hat, das sich Zeit genommen hat für eine Vorschau und so weiter und so fort. In diesem Sommer wird das ziemlich sicher anders sein. Da werdet ihr jetzt schon mit täglichen Fußballpodcasts zugeballert. Das hat immer mehr zugenommen, das ist der aktuelle Trend. Das heißt, zur EM wird es nicht mehr so sein, dass wir allein dadurch, dass wir jeden Tag eine Folge machen oder mindestens eine, schon mal Reichweite bekommen, sondern wir werden da anstinken. Wir werden hinter den Freundes, Kickers, Sport1, Sky und Springers dieser Welt finden wir irgendwo auf Platz 15 statt. Da guckt keiner mehr hin. Das heißt, das ist schon... Also manchmal verspüre ich da schon so einen Druck, muss ich sagen, den wir als Ansporn verstehen. Aber ich glaube, wir dürften uns jetzt nicht auf dem ausruhen, was wir aktuell machen, alles nur so weitermachen. Dann kann es schon sein, dass so Schleichen der Rasenfunkprobleme bekäme.
Ja, und dann kommen wir noch gleich zu dem Social-Video, das ich gerade schon angesprochen habe. Sind da schon Effekte spürbar, Max, durch die Veröffentlichung? Also für all diejenigen, die es noch nicht mitbekommen haben, vielleicht kurz zusammengefasst, wir veröffentlichen seit Anfang des Jahres ungefähr nach vielen Sendungen einen kurzen Hotcut, würde ich es mal sagen, von maximal 60 Sekunden bei TikTok als YouTube Short und als Instagram Real mit dem Grunde den knackigsten Aussagen der Sendung, mit den interessantesten Segmenten, das lassen wir, da kommen wir auch gleich nochmal dazu, von einem freien Cutter, mittlerweile sind es zwei, die wir dafür haben, produzieren. Max gibt dann nach der Sendung da so ein paar Ausschnitte durch ein paar Timecodes, exportiert entsprechende Segmente aus den Videos und das wird dann von dem Cutter für uns gemacht und danach wird es veröffentlicht. Jetzt ist die Frage, was war denn da bisher das Ergebnis? Kann man da irgendwas daraus lesen, Max? Gab es irgendwo eine Entwicklung in diesen Profilen? Gab es spürbare Auswirkungen auf die Feeds, auf die Hauptformate?
Also die spürbaren Auswirkungen auf die Hauptformate, die gab es noch nicht, aber das wäre jetzt auch noch nicht zu erwarten, muss man sagen. Das zum einen und zum anderen müssen das dann auch schon hohe Zahlen sein, damit die sich bemerkbar machen. Weil, um jetzt den Unterschied zu merken zwischen, keine Ahnung, 30.000 und 32.000 Downloads, müssen es halt schon 2.000 sein. Die Tausend, die mehr dazu kommen, die merken wir dann erstmal gar nicht so wirklich. Der Grund, warum wir das gemacht haben und der Grund, warum ich das noch nie im Rasenfunk erwähnt habe, dass wir jetzt bei TikTok sind, das ist jetzt tatsächlich eine Premiere, liebe HörerInnen, liegt daran, dass es eine Subkultur gibt von Fußball-Video-Content, in der der Rasenfunk nicht stattfindet. Und diese Subkultur, die kennt auch den Rasenfunk nicht, und zwar bei weitem nicht. Und deswegen war das Ziel, deswegen habe ich das nie im Rasenfunk gesagt, dass wir jetzt auch bei TikTok sind. Irgendwie freuen wir uns natürlich, wenn ihr uns alle da folgt, aber eigentlich wollten wir neue Leute da finden. Und wir wollten quasi dem Algorithmus auch die Möglichkeit bieten, uns neue Leute anzubieten und eben nicht quasi gleich wieder unsere Blase nachzubilden, die wir sowieso schon haben. Und das funktioniert sehr gut. Logischerweise funktioniert es nach den Mechanismen dieser Videoplattformen, die natürlich eigentlich doof sind und auch nicht so ganz zum Rasenfunk passen, nämlich je hotter der Take, desto heißer das Thema, oder desto netter der Zusammenschnitt, desto mehr wird darüber diskutiert. Ich bin aber sehr glücklich damit, dass wir, obwohl wir auch schon ein paar virale Videos hatten mit fünfstelligen View-Anzahlen, dass wir da bisher uns noch nicht schmutzig machen mussten. Also es wurde, logischerweise, es würden wir ja nie machen wollen. Aber wir haben noch nie irgendwas sinnverdreht zusammengeschnitten. Die Videos sind immer noch viel weniger knallig als die von anderen Teams, einfach weil, wenn jemand bei uns einen Nebensatz zu einem Team sagt, dann kommt der auch so halb ins Video noch und wird nicht irgendwie nach dem dritten Wort schon abgeschnitten und dann kommt der nächste Take rein. Also ich finde, in diesem Bereich Video-Kurzformate zu Fußball sind wir immer noch eines der ausgeruhteren Formate und das passt ja auch zum Rasenfunk. Und die Frage des Erfolges würde ich ja dann daran messen, sehen, dass Leute, die uns vorher nicht kannten, und da kann ich mit einem ganz entschiedenen Ja antworten, denn die Hauptantwort ist ganz oft, wer ist der Typ mit der Brille, warum redet der so, was willst du eigentlich, ihr habt doch alle keine Ahnung. Aber auch zum Teil natürlich inhaltliches Feedback, ich will jetzt gar nicht hier irgendwie ein TikTok-Bashing übergehen. Und das ist super, weil bei solchen Leuten will ich einfach nur platzieren, schau mal, es gäbe auch den Rasenfunk, vielleicht ist es was für dich. Und für fünf von hundert ist es dann was, und die wechseln dann vielleicht auch irgendwann die Plattform, weil ihnen dann die Einminutenschnipsel nicht mehr reichen, dann hören sie mal eine Sendung rein, egal auf welcher Plattform. Aber das muss halt noch wachsen. Aber ich bin eigentlich sehr zufrieden damit, und ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, ich war total gespannt darauf zu sehen, wie die ersten Einminutenzusammenschnitte von so 15-Minuten-Segmenten aus der Sendung sein würden. Und inhaltlich finde ich es dann immer selber, also man denkt sich selber manchmal, Mensch, ist ja krass, was wir eigentlich alles besprochen haben in diesem 15-Minuten-Segment, das ist schon cool.
Also ich muss sagen, ich bin ein bisschen positiv überrascht davon, wie gut das funktioniert als Video. Jetzt nicht, funktioniert auf der Plattform, da kann man sicherlich dann drüber streiten und da hängt natürlich vieles noch davon ab, dass wir besser sichtbar werden müssen und sowas, von vielen kleinen Details. Aber wie gut das funktioniert, diese Schnipsel aus so einer Analysesendung rauszunehmen und was Aussagekräftiges hinzubekommen, was natürlich immer, aber ich meine, ich konsumiere nun auch, war auch nicht der Erste, der mit TikTok als Konsument angefangen hat, aber konsumiere nun auch seit einem Jahr oder so relativ regelmäßig, TikTok weniger, meistens YouTube oder Instagram. Man gewöhnt sich so ein bisschen an diese Kurzformate und ich finde, das funktioniert relativ gut. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass es als Teaser, als Anreiz funktioniert. Ob es dann tatsächlich so ist, dass wir das irgendwann als Ergebnis in den Statistiken sehen, steht natürlich in den Sternen, ist dann eben auch, wie anfangs erwähnt, fraglich, ob wir es überhaupt entdecken würden. Ich denke, es wird jetzt auf absehbare Zeit, denn wir haben keinerlei negativen Outcome bisher damit, außer dass es Geld kostet, da kann man vielleicht auch noch einen kurzen Takt dazu sagen, aber ansonsten ist es durchweg positiv, der Ablauf funktioniert, die Veröffentlichung funktioniert. Wir werden das auf jeden Fall eine Weile durchziehen, auch schon müssen, um irgendwann zu entscheiden, lohnt es sich oder nicht.
Ja, das ist absolut wahr, aber ich möchte noch mal strapazieren, da gibt es eben eine eigene Subkultur, die sich rausbildet. Und es geht uns ja auch nicht immer bei allem, was wir machen, darum, immer mehr Reichweite und mehr Wachstum und mehr Geld zu haben. Ich denke, da spreche ich für uns beide, wir probieren halt einfach auch sehr gerne Sachen aus. Und wir sind schon beide so lange im Internet aktiv, dass wir schon mehrere Dinge sich entwickeln und wieder eingehen haben sehen. Aber die aktuellen Trends, die eben so Kurzformatvideos angeht, die werden nicht mehr weggehen. Das wird sich eher tatsächlich noch verschärfen. Und wir beide haben halt da eine Freude daran, dann da mitzumischen und zu gucken, können wir da nach unseren Konditionen, können wir da mitmachen und dann vielleicht auch Erfolg haben. Aber wenn wir jetzt in einem Jahr TikTok wieder zumachen würden oder nicht mehr so viel dafür bezahlen würden für Videos, und wir hätten keine 1000 Follower erreicht, also ich würde da nicht weit ins Bett gehen. Ich freue mich darüber, dass wir das jetzt mal ausprobieren und mal ein paar neue Leute dadurch kennenlernen.
Und ich glaube, es gibt auch noch den Aspekt, dass es ja auch für uns die Möglichkeit gibt, herauszufinden, ob wir in einem Medium, in dem wir bisher nicht vertreten waren, die Möglichkeit haben, mit Inhalten, wie wir sie uns vorstellen, und dann eben auch in kurzer Form, die sich ja immer noch unterscheiden von den Aussagen, die andere tätigen in dieser kurzen Zeit, und die wir ja bekommen, weil wir die Gäste einladen, die wir gut finden, da einfach auch unsere Inhalte platzieren können. Zwar nicht in der gewohnt langen Form, aber trotzdem ja unsere Inhalte, wofür wir stehen, die Gäste stehen, worauf wir stolz sind. Und ich finde, das ist auch ein Aspekt. Selbst wenn es mal nur für sich alleine funktioniert und sich gar nicht so sehr auf die Feeds auswirkt, kann es vielleicht auch positive Aspekte haben. Ob das dann am Ende was zur Refinanzierung beitragen kann, ist dann natürlich nochmal eine andere Frage. Und wie gesagt, auf der anderen Seite stehen Kosten. Also Finanzierung ist natürlich ein Thema unterm Strich. Aber erst mal muss es jetzt quasi als Test erst mal so funktionieren.
Bringt uns ja auch zu dem Aspekt, der ja auch nachgefragt wurde, ob die zusätzliche Videoproduktion für uns ein organisatorisches Problem geworden ist oder in sonstiger Form. Ich kann mal kurz das schildern, was sich für mich verändert hat. Also zum einen hat es dazu geführt, dass die Rasenfunk GmbH mir einen neuen Laptop bezahlen musste, denn der alte Rechner ist beim Rendering nicht mehr zurechtgekommen der Videos, dafür waren die zu lang. Wie war das? Ich glaube, ich hatte 1,1-fache Geschwindigkeit beim Rendering, der damals noch Schlusskonferenz, und dann wisst ihr ja, das musste ich dann über Nacht machen lassen, und wenn dann aber irgendwas schiefgegangen ist beim Rendering, musste ich es nochmal anstoßen. Jetzt habe ich hier einen neuen Laptop stehen, der war schon in den Materialkosten mit drin, die ich euch vorhin genannt habe. Das war das eine, was sich verändert hat. Das andere ist natürlich, dass sich mein Workflow jetzt verlängert hat. Also ich muss jetzt mehr Dinge machen, aber ich schaffe es inzwischen ganz gut, da nicht zu viel Zeit zu verlieren, und deshalb sind die Videos auch so rudimentär. Links der eine, rechts der andere, oder wenn es drei sind, ich in der Mitte, und die anderen beiden Gäste links und rechts. Das ist immer gleich, es gibt keine Zwischenschnitte, es gibt keine Bauchbinden, ich blende nicht den Namen des Kapitels ein, weil das sind alles Fehlerquellen und es kostet alles Zeit. Es geht relativ schnell, aber auch nur wegen des neuen Rechners, muss man wirklich sagen, weil der einfach sehr schnell rausrendert. Was noch dazugekommen ist, ist immer der Zusatzaufwand für Video-Schnipsel. Das hast du ja schon gesagt, da bauen wir immer einen kleinen Abbinder und ich lasse nochmal so ein Segment raus. Und was natürlich auch mehr Zeit kostet, ist dann der Upload zu YouTube. Ich meine, ich habe jetzt gerade, heute Vormittag habe ich das Schiedsrichter-Segment hochgeladen zu YouTube. Ich weiß gerade gar nicht, wann das bei YouTube erscheinen wird. Das waren drei Stunden 30, 17 Gigabyte. Also das mache ich dann auch nicht parallel zu der Sendung. Genau, muss man sagen. Aber ich finde, dass es eigentlich alles im Rahmen läuft. Und generell muss man sagen, die Videoproduktion, sie kostet Geld, sie kostet Zeit. Vielleicht kannst du gleich auch nochmal deine Meinung dazu sagen. Sie hat aber die Sendungen auch für die Podcast-Only-HörerInnen besser gemacht. Denn das, die Gäste, das wir uns jetzt sehen, ich hätte nie gedacht, welchen Effekt das haben würde auf Sendungen. Es ist viel, viel entspannter. Es ist gerade für Neulinge viel angenehmer. Denn vorher müsst ihr euch vorstellen, da haben die einen Browser-Tab vor sich gesehen und da konnten sie ihren Ausschlag sehen und den Ausschlag von Gästen, wenn sie was gesprochen haben, aber sie konnten sonst nichts sehen. Und jetzt bist du neu in einem Format und der Max stellt dir irgendeine geschlossene Frage, auf die es eigentlich eh schon keine ordentliche Antwort gibt. Und dann fängst du an zu reden und du redest eine Minute, zwei Minuten, drei Minuten und da wirst du unsicher, denn du bekommst kein Feedback. Auch deshalb habe ich früher viel öfter noch mhm, mhm, mhm gesagt, damit die Gäste wissen, ich bin bei dir, mach weiter, alles super. Und jetzt kann ich mir das alles sparen. Es wird viel weniger gerummgehümmt in den Sendungen von mir, weil wir sehen uns. Und dann siehst du, der andere nickt, es gucken dich beide an. Manchmal wird auch gegrinst, wenn du einen Spruch machst. Und deswegen ist die Sendequalität insgesamt besser geworden durch diese Videoaufzeichnung. Da bin ich total happy drüber. Und ich bin auch so froh, dass es jetzt eine technische Möglichkeit gibt, die bezahlbar ist und das auch in einer halbwegs okayen Qualität, abhängig von der Webcam der Leute, dann bereitstellt.
Ich würde auch sagen, wenn wir uns da vor drei Jahren drüber unterhalten hätten, dann hätten wir beide wahrscheinlich gesagt, ne, ne, Video, das ist in keiner Weise möglich. Und wir haben uns schon drüber unterhalten und haben über Video für Tribünengespräche gesprochen und sämtliche Ideen, aber nie hätte man damals, wäre man damals davon ausgegangen, dass die Schlusskonferenzen, Analysesendungen, egal wie die herkömmlichen Formate, jetzt mit so einer Regelmäßigkeit als Video veröffentlicht werden. Und wenn man das gegenüberstellt, den Mehraufwand gegenüber dem Nutzen, den es hat, sowohl für die Zuseherinnen und den Zuseher als auch für die Gästinnen und Gäste, dann würde man wahrscheinlich im Nachhinein sagen, naja, auf jeden Fall macht man das. Es ist ein großer Mehraufwand. Max hat es eben beschrieben, Hardware ist mehr nötig. Natürlich kostet es mehr Zeit, aber durch die Tools, die wir haben, auch das Tool, mit dem wir hier aufnehmen, mit dem wir auch diese Sendung aufnehmen, wird es schon wahnsinnig vereinfacht und es ist wirklich toll, dass wir das jetzt so konstant machen können, auf jeden Fall.
Ich gewöhne mich sogar langsam daran, dass ich immer von so einer LED-Lampe angeleuchtet werde. Aber das ist das erste, was ich ausmache, wenn die Sendung vorbei ist. Auch nach dieser Sendung.
Jetzt haben wir auch nur noch einen kleinen Abschnitt vor uns. Ein paar private Fragen, eigentlich konkret zwei. Ich gehe mal mit der weniger privaten ran. RTL hat eine zweite Staffel von 11 Leben veröffentlicht. Und es gab die Frage, ob du da etwas zu sagen möchtest, ob du eine Meinung zu hast.
Ich schäme mich ein bisschen dafür, aber ich habe die immer noch nicht gehört. Und ich kann euch gar nicht sagen, warum. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich irgendwie was doof fände oder so, oder dass ich mich mit denen zerstritten hätte. Ich wollte erst warten, bis alle Folgen da sind, weil so mache ich es immer bei solchen Podcasts. Und dann habe ich aber andere serielle Formate nachgehört. Und es liegt immer noch in meiner Podcast-Queue. Deswegen kann ich inhaltlich nichts dazu sagen. Wir sind alle cool miteinander. Ich finde es schön, dass Elfleben weitergeht. Und wie sich das entwickelt, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt selber gar nicht. Deswegen kann ich da leider nicht so viel sagen. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es da Beef oder so gäbe. Und das haben ja auch manche Leute geschrieben. Warum ich das nicht empfehlen würde im Rasenfunk, das liegt auch nicht daran, dass ich irgendwie böse wäre, dass es da eine zweite Staffel gibt und ich bei der nicht beteiligt bin. Ich habe ja gesagt, ich möchte nicht beteiligt sein. Also das ist alles easy. Es ist halt grundsätzlich so, dass ich, wenn ich das nicht explizit sage, und das kommt vielleicht zweimal im Jahr vor, ich ausschließlich Sachen im Rasenfunk empfehle, die ich gehört habe. Weil ich das eben wichtig finde. Weil ich viele Podcast-Empfehlungen aus anderen Podcasts mitnehme und diesen Hosts vertraue. Und ich den Eindruck habe, so ist es am korrektesten. Und dadurch, dass ich F-Leben noch nicht gehört habe, konnte ich es bisher auch noch nicht empfehlen. Deswegen, ja. Aber ansonsten gibt es ja glaube ich nicht so viel zu sagen.
Vor allem, wenn man es nicht gehört hat.
Leider, es ist mir wirklich unangenehm. Es ist wirklich ein bisschen peinlich.
Die zweite Frage geht natürlich. Stammhörerinnen und Hörer wissen es. Du bist auf Wohnungssuche.
Ja, wenn es denn so wäre. Also, ihr habt ja alle den großen Ausschlag mitbekommen, weil er ja bis in den Rasenfunk hineinreichte mit nettevermietergesucht.de und ich habe mir vorher schon eine ganze Weile überlegt, will ich das wirklich machen? Weil a, trifft es ja viele Leute, die mir gar nicht helfen können und b, will man ja eigentlich diesen Privatkram gar nicht so sehr in den Rasenfunk reinholen. Ich hatte aber das Gefühl, es wäre nötig, diesen größtmöglichen Ausschlag zu machen. Und was soll ich sagen? Der Fakt, dass ich immer noch keine Wohnung gefunden habe, hat mich leider bestätigt. Es war leider wirklich nötig. Ich hatte natürlich noch andere Ausbaustufen. Das war nur eine von mehreren Dingen, die ich gemacht habe. Also hier auch Halb-Harlaching oder Ganz-Garlaching ist auch mit Zetteln von mir beklebt worden. Ich habe Anzeigen anderswo geschaltet und so weiter und so fort. Ihr müsst mir jetzt auch keine Tipps schicken, liebe Hörer. Das haben einige von euch gemacht. Das ist ganz lieb gemeint. Aber ich habe schon so auf dem Schirm, was man machen kann, um eine Wohnung zu finden. Aktuell gibt es da leider noch keine Neuigkeiten. Es war zwischendurch schwierig. Also es gab auch schon Absagen und so weiter. Es ist genauso schwierig, wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe, weil es eben ein Zimmer zu viel ist für München und ein Einkommen zu wenig. Also das vierte Zimmer und dass ich nur ein Einzelankommen bin, das ist das Problem. Und dann muss man auch sagen, das war zumindest bei einer Wohnung der Fall, die ich mir angeguckt habe, die tatsächlich rausgefallen ist, weil da hätte ich den Rasenfunk nicht produzieren können. Das wäre einfach aufgrund der baulichen Konstruktion nicht so gegangen, dass man das irgendwie, ja, wäre einfach nicht möglich gewesen. Und ein Büro anzumieten wäre A, teuer, und B, passt das eigentlich auch nicht in die Produktionsform des Rasenfunks rein, weil der kurze Weg vom Skyreceiver zum Rechner schon oft wichtig ist und auch der kurze Weg vom Rechner zum Bett, wenn ich dann mal wieder nachts die Frauensendung veröffentlicht habe. Also das gab es auch schon. Aber ja, also wenn ihr was wisst in München, sagt gerne Bescheid. Vielen Dank für die Mails, die ich gekriegt habe, die einfach nur lauteten, ich komme aus Hamburg, aber ich drücke dir die Daumen und grüße an den einen Nazi, der sich gemeldet hat. Du hast mich nicht damit ärgern können.
Sehr gut, ganz wichtig. Dann bleibt eigentlich nur noch die traditionelle Frage von Hermes Milner, Herr Oster, wie fühlen Sie sich?
Ich bin froh, dass wir häufig in der Zeit geblieben sind, weil ich weiß, Frank, dass es für dich jetzt auch gleich weitergeht. Deswegen fühle ich mich gut. Ich bin schon mittelerschöpft. Ich habe gerade noch Bauchkrummeln, was die EM angeht, weil ich das noch nicht organisiert bekommen habe. Und ich eigentlich das schon gerne vor zwei Wochen alles fertig gehabt hätte, aber das war aus ganz verschiedenen Gründen nicht möglich. Es ist schon sehr viel gerade. Der Royal war immer ein Brett, jetzt ist es ein komplett anderes Brett. Jetzt ist es so ein, als würde man sich in den Wüstensand reinstellen. Vorher war es so, dass es war, als würde man an einem Fließband arbeiten. Und dann am Schluss veröffentlicht man so etwas, macht aber die Tür zu und kann sich davon distanzieren. Jetzt ist es so, dass ich am Fließband arbeite und gleichzeitig um mich herum der Wüstensturm tobt mit dem Feedback zu allen möglichen Sendungen und mit Input zu laufenden Sendungen und so weiter. Das ist schon ein bisschen viel, aber das ist ja auch mein Problem und ich kann da ja auch einen Umgang mit finden. Ich glaube, den finde ich auch damit. Also grundsätzlich schon alles gut. Ich freue mich mega auf alles, was noch kommt. Ich glaube, es könnte ein ganz fantastisches Rasenfunk-Jahr werden. Ich finde es so schön, dass die Dinge, die wir uns überlegen, immer klappen. Wir haben noch nie eine Entscheidung getroffen, die wir zurückdrehen mussten. Da macht es sich bezahlt, dass wir immer lange drüber reden, dass wir uns Zeit lassen, dass wir noch nie was einfach so ganz spontan entschieden haben, ohne vorher schon mal drüber nachgedacht zu haben.
Ja oder zumindest, wenn es vielleicht auch nicht ideal läuft, könnte man den Shop vielleicht in die Kategorie nehmen, dass es aber dann auch kein wirklicher Fail ist, sondern dass wir dann einfach nach einer Zeit sagen, ok, das hat sich jetzt so nicht gelohnt, das lassen wir halt dann wieder bleiben. Und dann ist es auch gut. Mir geht es da genauso. Ich finde das auch gut. Da hat sich unsere Klausur im Idealfall zweimal pro Jahr auch bewährt, in der wir schon manche überraschendes Outcome hatten, das wir vorher selber nicht dachten, wo gar keine ganz großen Entscheidungen auf dem Tisch lagen und dann doch gefällt wurden. Da waren wir glaube ich auch schon das eine oder andere mal recht mutig. Und das finde ich auch ganz gut, dass wir das dann auch sein können und Dinge verändern können. Und ich glaube, wir sind an einigen Dingen, das Intro mag ich da mal erwähnen. Du hast es ja heute schon erwähnt, an einigen Dingen hing dann auch das Herzblut so ein bisschen. Und da Veränderungen vorzunehmen, ist immer besonders schwierig. Aber das muss dann halt manchmal trotzdem sein. Und genauso die Namen der Feeds, die Schlusskonferenz war eigentlich unvorstellbar, dass dieser Name wegfällt. Und aus heutiger Sicht sagt man, naja, so what? Das hat jetzt halt passiert und geht weiter.
Ja, ja, ist ein guter Aspekt. Und gleichzeitig muss man auch dazu sagen, dass wir gesegnet sind mit einer sehr verständnisvollen Community. Also ich finde, das muss man so lobhudeleimäßig sich das jetzt anhört. Aber wir wissen auch, dass wir euch im Grunde eigentlich alles zumuten können. Wir könnten uns jetzt sogar umbenennen und nicht mehr Rasenfunk heißen. Dann fändet ihr das alles traurig. Aber wenn wir das einmal erklären in der Sendung, warum wir es gemacht haben, dann geht ihr das alles mit. Und es gibt ganz selten Misstrauen uns gegenüber. Wir waren sogar richtig davon überrascht, als das mal der Fall war, als wir GmbH werden wollten. Da hat uns doch irgendjemand Steuervermeidung oder irgendwie so vorgeworfen. Und das war so unüblich für die Rasenfunk-Community, dass uns das richtig überrascht hat. Neben dem Effekt, dass das leider tatsächlich im Gegenteil der Fall ist bei der GmbH. Aber das ist wirklich ein großes Privileg. Und das einzige, was tatsächlich schade ist, ist, wir haben jetzt einen zehnten Geburtstag vor uns. Viele andere befreundete Podcasts haben den auch. Der Milan Ton ist jetzt zehn Jahre alt geworden. Der Vertical Pass wird jetzt zehn Jahre alt. Radio Nucular wird jetzt zehn Jahre alt. Total interessant. Der reingemachte Podcast ist jetzt wieder da. Nach gefühlt zehn Jahren Pause. Das ist das einzige, was so ein bisschen schade ist. Da werden wir es, glaube ich, nicht schaffen, irgendwas Großes zu machen oder so. Das ist einfach nicht drin. Dafür liegt der zehnte Geburtstag zu doof. Dafür ist dieses Jahr zu anstrengend. Mit zu vielen Umschwingen. Aber vielleicht feuern wir dann den elften Geburtstag. Das würde ja auch zum Rasenfunk passen, irgendwie. Aber Frank, wie geht es denn dir?
Haha, gut eigentlich. Ganz gut. Ich kann nicht klagen. Ich finde, was den Rasenfunk angeht, für mich sehr schade, dass ich mich über die Jahre so weit vom Fußball entfernt habe. Aber ich habe es mehrfach probiert. Daran lässt sich nicht wirklich was drehen. Das hatte jetzt die Konsequenz von einem halben oder dreiviertel Jahr, dass ich auch sämtliche Abos dahingehend beendet habe, weil ich habe es schlicht nicht mehr genutzt. Es war einfach wirklich das letzte Jahr schon ziemlicher Blödsinn dafür noch zu zahlen. Der Rasenfunk ist jetzt meine einzige Verbindung zum Fußball, sozusagen neben Deutschlandfunk Sport, jeden Morgen vor den Nachrichten die vier Minuten. Das ist immer noch ein bisschen schade. Dem traue ich ein bisschen nach. Aber das ist halt so ein Trauern, weil ich gerne näher dran wäre. Aber ich merke, dass mir einfach völlig das Interesse fehlt dafür. Und es kommt nicht wieder. Ich habe eigentlich gedacht, ich brauche mal so eine Jahrpause. Dann kommt es schon wieder. Ich kriege natürlich irgendwie alles Wichtige mit. Der Rasenfunk ist dafür ideal. Ich freue mich auch dafür, die Bestätigung zu bekommen, dass das, was wir machen, funktioniert. Aber ich muss halt immer mehr sagen, das, was du machst in erster Linie. Du hast es vorhin angeschnitten, dass irgendwann mal geplant war, dass wir zusammen moderieren. Aus anderen Gründen ist es dazu nicht gekommen. Aber dass ich mittlerweile inhaltlich so weit davon weg bin, ärgert mich ein bisschen, wenn man das so sagen kann.
Aber es liegt am Geschäft, es liegt nicht an dir, Frank. So deutlich, wie du es tatsächlich sagen willst. Ja, aber ich habe mir das auch gedacht. Ich habe den FC Bayern-Part, weiß gerade nicht, also er wird ziemlich sicher nach diesem Tribünengespräch erst erscheinen. Den habe ich gestern Abend aufgenommen mit Stefan Meyer, den kennst du ja auch gut. Und das war im Grunde ein Gespräch, bei dem zufällig noch das Band lief. Also ganz andere Struktur als all die anderen Royalfolgen. Ich habe mich aber so wohl gefühlt, dass ich das einfach ablaufen lassen. Und danach habe ich mir original gedacht, krass, solche Gespräche hatten wir früher auch, wir zwei. Früher war es manchmal noch so, dass wir wegen Rasenfunk einen Call gemacht haben und dann haben wir über irgendwelche Bayern-Trainer gesprochen und so weiter. Und das ist jetzt leider gar nicht mehr so. Aber so ist es halt.
So verändern sich die Dinge. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, nur um das auch klarzustellen, habe ich natürlich zum Rasenfunk selber die engste Verbindung und den größten Spaß daran, diese Dinge rund um den Fußball, was beim Rasenfunk passiert, mitzuentscheiden, mitzuentwickeln, mitzudenken. Aber es ist halt immer weniger aus einem Fußball-Fan-Bezug. Und natürlich war es bei mir sowieso nie der ernsthaft journalistische Bezug. Der Blick dafür ist natürlich da, dadurch, dass wir uns ja viel darüber unterhalten, was man eben journalistisch machen kann im Rasenfunk. Aber der Fan-Bezug oder der leidenschaftliche Fußball-Bezug ist halt leider einfach weg. Aber so entwickeln sich die Dinge.
So entwickeln sich die Dinge. Wir haben zum Glück noch andere Themen, über die wir miteinander sprechen können.
Mehr als genug.
Nicht nur.
Den Rasenfunk. Frank, ich glaube, wir sind durch, oder? Ich weiß nicht.
Das Dokument ist am Ende und wir sind es nicht.
Gott sei Dank, aber …Ja, aber was wir noch tun müssen, ist, wir wollen auch an dieser Stelle natürlich ein paar SupporterInnen danken. Da kannst du sehr gerne mal in den Signal-Chat von uns beiden schauen. Dann würde ich doch sagen, da mache ich die ersten. Und danke ihnen. Und dann kannst du die weiteren dann nehmen. Ich bedanke mich herzlich bei Atta, bei Birneweich, bei Björn und beim Ruhrpott-Frosch.
Und außerdem bedanken wir uns bei Thomas, der Stehplatz-Helden, Jan-Philipp, Oliver B.,
Vielen herzlichen Dank. Auf rasenfunk.de/supporterscluberfahrtihr, wie man uns unterfahren kann, äh, unterstützen kann. Auf kiosks.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr uns bitte, bitte tassen und die letzten Hoodies und so weiter abkaufen und abonniert sehr gerne den Rasenfunk Nationalteams-Video. Da gibt es dann alles zu EM. In diesem Sinne, danke dir, Frank.
Danke, Max.
Macht's gut, ihr alle. Bleibt gesund.
Bis bald, ciao ciao.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser. Für heute.